okay Leute also hier deutscher web video
Preis 2012 ti und sind die Abräumer hier
herzlich
Glückwunsch so wir haben so ein kohlend
wir habek die erü reingestoptn
piniktischniktisch das ist der Jurytisch
übrigens das möchte ich mal
sagen
okay
ja das das ist der Preis für das sind
die besten ja
Publikumspreis nein war
nicht es war eure message genau unsere
Message das beste also vom Publikum als
das beste Video 2012 gTA real life ja
aber sind wir doch mal ehrlich das liegt
einfach daran dass wir ein ultra geiles
Publikum haben wir haben alle für uns
gewotet das ist unglaublich geil weil
diese
pornostimme ja natürlich ich weiß nicht
ob wirklich keine por fre
nein aber man muss mal sagen es liegt
halt wirklich an Zuschauer es ist der
Publikumspreis und es sind einfach die
Zuschauer genau das Ding was Youtube
halt einfach ausmacht weil ohne die
Zuschauer ganz ehrlich da würden wir
alle heute nicht hier sitzen ist einfach
so was woll das ist eine pornostimme die
er da hat sorry dass ich wieder darauf
zurückkomme ich glaub du verstellst die
in Wirklichkeit ist das voll
hoch komd nach
Hause wo hast du früer
PU
nein das war jetzt W der pornostimme nee
ich bin seit 10 Jahren tatsächlich
selbstständig und versuche mich
durchzubeißen in der Gaming Branche und
jetzt das hier guck dir das mal an das
keiner du hast geschafft du hast ein
Bild auf dem sch mit
Minecraft von
gerade Applaus Applaus appla Applaus
appla appla so du bistensckom
gen wir müssen uns noch Treffen habe ich
gehört ne ja Interview ist ja nicht so
ein Problem aber wir wollen ja richtig
talken talken du meinst jetzt richtig so
ein so ein einfach wie bei hier wie
heißt die vier bei krachten oder was
vier bei Kra was war das denn vier bei
krachten glaub es war eine Anspielung
auf zwei bei Karl
was Christof ja aber ich guck sowas
nicht guck kein Fernsehen guck kein fern
ich bin nicht ich bin so selten krank
das guckt man ja nur wenn man krank ist
oder mitten im krachten finde ich auch
cool das aber mehr so ein bisschen so so
eine gay
Sendung Wahnsinn okay entschuldigung
aber als du vor 10 Jahren dass sowas
passieren würde hast du wahrscheinlich
auch überhaupt nicht mit gerechnet oder
ich will ganz ehrlich sein ich hätte
damit auch nicht gerechnet als ich
angefangen habe Let's Plays zu machen so
im Leben nicht so im Leben nicht weil im
Grunde genommen wir wollten Gaming
Reviews machen dann haben wir angefangen
die Games selber zu zocken so ein
bisschen Leute zu unterhalten aber das
hier ist alles
so das ist zu hoch einfach das ist viel
zu hoch sensationell sensationell den
habe ich mir selber ausgedacht echt
super Idee ja wie ist die Lage
eigentlich sag do mal gen darf ich dir
die Sprüche klauen mach doch bitte fang
fang mal an wie ist die Lage geht so
geht so war schon mal besser weißt du
drei Preise abgeräumt letztens war es
fünf weiß ich bin enttäuscht okay okay
gut dann müssen wir dich gleich noch
trüsten auf der Aftershow Party ich bin
sehr gerne da und ich hoffe wir trinken
auch ein bisschen Vollmilch alle
zusammen das machen wir und wie sind bei
euch so die Gefühle ja ungefähr
eigentlich hat er alles gesagt bei uns
genauso die das nennt manopy und das ist
ja nicht
so ist natürlich unglaublich wir freuen
uns so total wir danken unserer Familie
unseren Eltern uns fre dramatische Musik
druntergelegt könen guck mal bisste
dramatische Musik an dieser Stelle ich
ma die dramatische also okay ja okay
also happy eine Frage genau was macht
was macht jetzt noch worspiel Sex was
nee was wir noch machen ja köl trinken
Party Party okay party party party in
diesem Sinne Part und wir gucken mal was
nächstes Jahr
wird machen das so du schmeiß ELV Kostüm
und wir gehen jetzt rüber Party und was
mache ich im Elvis Kostüm ja tanzen wie
immer wie letztens auch auf der
Betriebsfeier oder du hast ein Video
davon angestellt
ne ich hab mein Madonna Kostüm okay
meine Hotpants g das
ma wir haben jetzt e woll endk aber
vielleicht machen wir noch mal den wsch
aber die können wir jetzt zusammen
machen 1 2